shadow secretary to the treasury pat
mcfadden is here he would say that
though wouldn't he i'm guessing you'd
say the same
he's right because what we've been
witnessing in
the last few days is a festival of
irresponsibility
where one tory leadership candidate
after another has been promising
tens of billions of pounds in unfunded
tax cuts and there's only two ways
in the end that they can fund those one
is by much more borrowing and the other
which is where they really want to get
to as the chancellor himself has said is
20 cuts
in departmental spending now when we've
got
six and a half million people waiting
for nhs care we've got a generation of
school children who need help to catch
up from the education laws during the
pandemic we've got victims of crime
waiting years to get access to justice
in the courts just think what that level
of cuts would mean and that is the
agenda which one by one the candidates
are setting out you know it's not about
cuts in the services about cuts they
would say in the flab in the day-to-day
running of the departments
they can't achieve the level of tax cuts
they're talking about it but the depart
you know the chancellor himself the
current chancellor has said he wants to
get to 20
in departmental uh cuts you can't do
that just by getting rid of it he's
costed it in the education department
let me just finish in the education
department and he's confident that he
could do it with other departments as
well if you look at the education
department that he was running we
haven't even reached the level of
investment in pupils that we had 12
years ago when this government came to
power so i don't think his record in
education gives us hope for what he
would do if he became prime minister
um
what do you make of the suggestions that
i want to come to the vote of no
confidence in just a second but rishi
sunak being a socialist
i don't think he's a socialist but what
he is
unlike the other candidates is a a
candidate with a recent record and that
recent record is a number of tax rises
including a breach in the manifesto on
which they were elected uh we're the
only country in
the g7 to be putting up taxes this year
and what's wrong for taxes and then
criticizing them for trying to do tax
cuts which one do you want what what i
want is responsible budget making and a
long term plan for growth and when you
stand back
from this leadership contest and you
look at the debate the thing that
strikes you is the superficial nature of
it the biggest problem facing this
country is lack of long-term economic
growth there's a major report out today
from the resolution foundation showing
that middle-income families in the uk
are now over 8 000 pounds a year less
well-off than comparable flat families
in countries like france germany and the
netherlands that wasn't always the case
it wasn't the case at the start of the
century but it's a product of 12 long
years of anemic economic growth under
the tories that's the big challenge
facing the country and it's the thing
that's completely missing from this
dutch auction of unfunded tax cut
pledges whatever you say there's still
another couple years of this government
at least you went for a vote of
confidence in the prime minister
yesterday wanted one you didn't get one
and you're very cross about it
well look uh it's usually open to
oppositions to table a vote of no
confidence uh i suspect boris johnson
would say that only matters to mps you
know his his calculation is always
cynicism about these things but we felt
it was right
when his own ministers have obviously
lost confidence in him most of his own
mps have lost confidence in him that's
why he's had to resign in the first
place and even since
his resignation was announced there have
been more revelations
about uh
unauthorized meetings with ex-kgb agent
alexander lebedev
when he was foreign secretary a real
risk to our national security another
story about trying to get a job for
someone who was in some sort of
relationship allegedly can we just throw
that in there please
and i we cannot allow this man to just
continue with no accountability for
another two months in office that's why
we tabled the motion and he's clearly
running scared of it well he's not there
is he because he's he's not you could
stay running scared he could say nah not
gonna
well he's done he's not going to ask a
result much you can do unless you have a
vote of no confidence in the government
and you're not going to do that because
you'll lose
we write our own motions we don't take
dictation from the tory party he clearly
didn't want to allow parliament to have
this vote and that makes it all the
worse that he will continue
for another two months in office
despite the repeated scandals the
repeated lies and the record that you
know the degradation of the office that
has been epitomized by his time and
there's not a thing you can do about it
which tells my viewers everything they
need to know about the strength of the
labour party at the moment well the
parliamentary arithmetic is what it is
but we will keep pushing our alternative
and the voters themselves will get to
decide the choice when the time comes
yeah that's two years away what about a
vote of no confidence in the government
well as i say we write our own motions
we table the vote of no confidence
they've rolled out of order uh you know
that's the motion we table we're not
going to take dictation on exactly what
the motion says from the conservative
party um in the meantime which of the
eight remaining candidates could labour
most do business with until you feel
that you're on the other should be on
the other side of the house it's for the
conservative party to
choose its own leader we will
you know take that result we will fight
the next election against whoever they
decide but my overall reflection on the
contest as i said is that the debate
they're having is too small for the
countries the problems that the country
faces it's not just about a little
auction on who's got the biggest tax cut
it's about how we make this country more
prosperous for the long term and how we
make its people more prosperous and
that's what's missing from this debate
are you not naming one because you think
it'll be a case of death for them
no
it's a matter for them i don't care who
they pick
because uh we've got our own leader
we've got our own program that's what
we'll fight on it's up to the tory party
who they pick whoever they pick will not
be able to escape 12 long years in power
12 years of anemic growth and the impact
that's had on our public services and on
people's standard of living good to talk
to you thanks for joining us